one of the important aspects of
interpreting symbolism in culture is the
capacity to discern patterns not only
within stories but also across them the
capacity to notice these patterns will
help us see when certain directions
certain deep movements and changes are
taking form in culture it will give us
the capacity to let's say read the signs
of the times sometimes an understanding
of symbolism can be used for purposes of
propaganda and to push certain social
agendas
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
now in the movies I've interpreted until
today many of them have a certain tribe
which I have mentioned now and again in
passing this trope is the replacing of
the masculine hero by a feminine one we
see this pattern not only in the fact of
certain replacements but it often
appears as a pattern within the stories
themselves Jasper
it wasn't really ghostbusters material
so it's not just that there are more
lead feminine characters and stories
which could have been you know an
opportunity for good storytelling but it
is the very act of supplanting and
replacing which is often shown as a
story trope and this trope becomes
boldly apparent especially when we see
this pattern appear across several
movies the pattern can take a variety of
forms it can appear as a strange play on
the masculine virtue of wanting to save
others though now the male character
sacrifices himself in order to make way
for a feminine character which replaces
him we see this for example in the movie
Logan well Wolverine sacrifices himself
to make way for his female clone there's
also Kay in Blade Runner 2049 giving up
his place as the son to make room for
the daughter you imagined it was you oh
you did but there are many other such
scenes in several movies sometimes the
masculine character will be humiliated
and made to look useless I plan not
commander right wasn't it lay his last
official act to demote you for your
dreadknot plan there are several
occasions where the masculine character
will willingly get out of the way to
make place for a feminine replacement in
the final scene of the movie Mad Max
fury road after tossing the dead body of
the tyrannical father max presents the
female lead to the people who clamor for
her and Max then gets off this
escalating elevator in order to let all
the feminine characters ascend to
replace the toppled authority in these
movements when sees the raw power play
that is happening in the cultural
narrative it is not about parody about
equality and all those virtues rather
the current social move appears as
revolutionary it's about inverting the
traditional higher
putting it upside down at first glance
there are those who might cheer to see
such a replacement you know it's about
time that women make room for themselves
but things are not always what they seem
by simply filling masculine social
tropes with female characters who embody
those very tropes it might not so much
be an elevation of the feminine that
we're seeing but rather a blind
attachment to masculine qualities as the
ones that truly matter as if being on
top as if being physically strong a
warrior and a leader is somehow more
virtuous than beauty than the caring and
intimate connections of our private
realm there have been very powerful
female characters who embody the
feminine in profound ways for example
Galadriel and the Lord of the Rings has
been a perfect type she disarms men by
her depth of vision by her insight by
her beauty her grace and even in her
terrible moment she shows us the terror
of the feminine that she could be as
terrible as the dawn as treacherous as
the sea all will love her and despair
such a character is far more engaging
and encompassing than simply making the
female character a feisty badass who it
turns out is a better fighter than all
her male counterparts character is like
Galadriel but also the wonderful and
rich female heroines we find in Miyazaki
films take into account the whole range
of human emotions and activity which is
primordial and understanding what it
means to be fully human male and female
once we see though the pattern of
replacement we can then begin to
understand the storytelling choices made
in recent movies as soaking in an
ideological zeitgeist we could say so
for example it would not have been
difficult to have Luke Skywalker in the
last Jedi returned to the resistance in
order to lead one last grand show of
heroism before passing on
but having him appear only as a mirage
cut that hope short and crystallized the
ascension of Rey who had already been
shown to not need a man and is
constantly shown upstaging the already
established masculine character you're
afraid I bypassed the compressor now I
could have analyzed many movies in order
to give a detailed symbolic
understanding of what is happening but I
thought that one scene from the recent
movie Wonder Woman encapsulate the
structure most succinctly so the scene
is happening in a village the movie has
already set up that this village is a
kind of microcosm of what is happening
more broadly in the war so after
clearing the village of all the enemy
soldiers there's still this sniper
shooting people from the church tower
which looms above the center of the
village the fact that the sniper is at
the top of the church is very important
in terms of symbolism just as we can
understand the sniper in the very
vertical tower shooting is rifled down
at the people below as a form of
tyrannical masculine power we don't have
to be Freudian to notice that the
incapacity of Charlie write their own
sniper to take a shot himself is an
image of the flipside of tyrannical
power that is it is a form of male
impotence so this solution which appears
suggested by Steve Trevor is for the men
to get under the steel shield and prop
up Wonder Woman
now the mechanics of the situation did
not need the men to do that we had
already seen Wonder Woman leap up at
least that high and escalate stone
buildings but it was important that the
men lift her up just as it was important
to have that escalating platform in Mad
Max to show the ascent in order to
establish the new hierarchy in the
village scene we can now easily
understand the importance of the church
tower as Wonder Woman the goddess but
also the god
leaps up and destroys his masculine
symbol of power of tradition of
Christianity only to then appear in the
rubble
above the villagers replacing the tower
itself in order to receive the praise of
the villagers and the scene of the
church tower is also the first of this
repeating pattern in the movie where we
see Wonder Woman lifted up into the air
in order to kill her enemies culminating
in taking the form of the cross and
striking this masculine god of war and
of tyranny from above with lightning
bolts and finally when we see the enemy
is defeated as the new day rises Wonder
Woman is then shown at the centre of the
new world she represents a world that
believes in love as the German soldiers
suddenly forget their violent ways and
start to show camaraderie even with
their former enemies now there are two
things to understand one is that we have
to be careful we have to be careful not
to reduce our vision to polemics as many
have done we cannot reduce the movies to
this trope we must not be blinded by
politics we always need to stay
clear-headed enough to see the symbolic
patterns appear where they appear that
is why I only occasionally mentioned all
of this when analyzing many of these
movies before such as Logan or gravity
having said that the second thing to
understand is that we also need to see
the pattern and I can surmise that many
of you have watched my past movie
interpretations without noticing how
this pattern reappeared in many of the
movies that I chose you see if such a
scene as this one in Wonder Woman had
appeared on its own you know and as some
freak event it might have been exactly
that it might have been an exception but
the recurring pattern is not only
significant but it is often quite
deliberate and it is being cheered by
certain factions of the political sphere
for example in an article critiquing the
latest Marvel Universe movie
and the wasp in which this very pattern
of supplanting and replacing his playing
itself out for example notice the
composition of the posters this
journalist praises not only the fact of
the strength and smarts of the leading
female which would be understandable and
maybe even laudable but she also
rejoices in how the male character is
shown as hapless with his successes due
only to accident the author of the
article complains that the MCU is not
going far enough but is moving in the
right direction and she looks forward to
seeing how the MCU will deal with the
introduction of Captain Marvel who has
already been a focal point of propaganda
in recent Marvel comics and so to those
of us who look for symbolic patterns we
should all pay attention at as this
trope this sign of the times
shows every sign of being on an
accelerating ascent